yeah welcome to this video I am a bit
late here but had a technical issue but
ok it's a 15-minute game so it's not
totally bad this is one minute loss I
the good old gambit him you know ok I'm
going again Knight f6 black can also
play d 5 which is considered the most
solid but also very boring d5 ed Queen
d5 often leading to some what yeah less
than exciting and game this is a little
bit little bit more um yeah a little bit
more fighting this the snide of six line
okay hmm
hmm I can take this pawn now once III
but it definitely will be some kind of
compensation I guess huh yeah this looks
like the most solid move d5 d6 also but
d5 cannot be bad let's say C takes d4 I
get Bishop g4 that cannot be bad looks
like very solid development um Bishop e7
now Bishop b4 check should be for check
93 I wonder if I may be Knight a5 bishop
see tool I wonder if I can do something
against his Bishop here 94 but Tennessee
can probably just take
hmm ok let's play a simple move yeah
Knight a5 Bishop see to this kind of
thing here he had actually just make a
little bit more sense now maybe night
see for me ok so what does this actually
mean you gag Antigua take them or bishop
age five why not
mm yeah he got in age three but I still
expect him to play Bishop c2 just
allowing me to take on b3 is kind of
strange I could have taken only three
after age three actually maybe I should
have done that ok so now I I can and
probably should take especially after g4
weekend all this light squares I should
take yeah I interesting now here we have
a situation where whites king will never
be safe I mean he has moved almost all
of his pawns ok so I can't play this one
and I will I have not cashed lot yet ok
so Queen d7 looks very very normal
mmm Jim
yeah it's more than one good way to play
this really I one now okay I'm doing
something else this was interesting um
the quiet one question was is aged for a
move for him or not with me playing age
for myself I'm isolating this pawn on d5
from the rest of blacks camp and my
ideas play 97 fa to e6 and detect the
spawn and possibly just win it i also
have rook age 5 or bishop age 5 yeah so
this move I can go also Queen d7 Bishop
f5 now yeah maybe in some situations
let's say he plays rook g1 then I'm
playing Bishop f5 and then it gets kind
of awkward maybe I should have okay
mm-hmm John now this night stop doing
that much on b6 I still should have
started with 97 okay it's not really a
big deal
I think the black position is already L
or is so much better then it's not that
it's not mattering that much
when you form maybe but ok this looks ok
here anyway ok so now the night
definitely should go to g6 or ecigs may
be going to be five or something like
that or maybe here night on g6 is also
ok and I can maybe open it up with f6 I
could have played that actually but ok
first I want to get this night involved
get all pieces in the game yeah one
thing that is maybe happening as
something like Bishop f2 not trying to
try to get the get the pawn
but I mean it opens the age file
yeah putting it on g6 and then known
afterwards I can also consider to play
f6 at the right moment yeah this is just
mean c 6 a-6 is totally closing the
queenside nothing's ever going to happen
there
a six closes the queenside okay that's
the wrong expression I mean it prevents
any kind of like v4b 5 and so on and i'm
going for 96 and f6 then okay yeah maybe
b5 is some it's a bit irritating see
takes be root b7 rook c7 sorry but I
have Queen to be six and then 96 taking
this regard
so queen bee six
fatigue 7s is just a check right now it
mostly is yeah I thought Bishop d8 now
is is the most solid option and now
let's kick this look out here
now if I wanted to go night is six but
now there's no no but I can do that rook
c8 is not really a problem
k it seems he's coming back to this
possible idea of capturing on h4 ok so
I'm going to play g6 I can also go to e4
actually yeah let's do that
putting this on the most active square
yeah he can take that but it's not it's
not helping him that much this is not a
very important porn on H form at least i
think so i can just push also here maybe
i should should just do that just push
things here
okay hmm and it's no use in giving away
any material here I rather push those it
doesn't have many moves now this night
is tied to the bishop on each form
probably as to who I should probably
move as a bishop away from age 4 let's
say F to something like that
okay that's very that's a very strong
medicine everything is hanging here for
white if i take f3 now i'm no use in
pretending i'm thinking i'm taking this
here anyway okay so it takes six and i
can take h for now as well for a huge
material advantage
or just Queenie six I mean it's pretty
attractive actually just take it with
the Queen whereas the compensation for
the exchange and everything ok but rook
takes EF seven now that's not necessary
come on this is this is very simple just
take down ok now let's say push-up be 64
root d8 I can also simply castle short
then just a rookie 8 it's the first
simple idea though ok what is he doing
bish no Queen a form maybe Queen a
forest idea ok I'm just guzzling him
that sets really probably the best move
brooksy a dozen Bishop e3 SN we should
be 3m was interesting in any case but he
had this check which was kind of
irritating ok so just trade stuff here
yeah he ultimately pushed his pants too
far and left many weaknesses behind it's
very difficult to to come back from that
much or that many square weaknesses that
he had Square and porn weaknesses okay
and there is no direct tactic or
something but I can I kind of attack be
true
and the rook is hanging on c1 so it's
definitely not so easy for him to keep
things together
e okay so hmm proxy for Queen B to Queen
it is not so not so convincing but I can
also give the check it is also quite
good Roger really isn't there some kind
of tactic here mmm I cannot check let's
just keep it simple
looxcie too it's the simple threat and
his speech these pieces here I'm not
really really doing that much
yeah that looks like the last last hope
okay so yeah it's probably easier so
i'll just take after pawn takes rook see
292 queen bee two edges it is simply
over i guess and okay i cannot Queenie 6
i'm trading rookie eight and just pick
up this pawn it's nothing going on yeah
it looks okay don't see any any kind of
serious calendar play okay I'm here
I can give this chitchat first it's
actually quite good it doesn't have any
any good square really I hear it's
running into the check but there wasn't
wasn't anything decent yeah if he goes
would have gone back then Queen 83 was
even possible I guess I can give check
there or up to 20 that's quite a quite a
nice choice check on h1 king of 2 we
should be six trick now I'm not seeing a
med so let's take this yeah but now i
can give this check what is there a
quicker way now let's just take the
Queen but okay if I give this check king
of to Bishop b6 trick King 2 g-3 okay
there might be a maid but this is just
the Queen white resign yeah Amy simply
created too many weaknesses here right
right out of the opening um okay if we I
think here this is this is pretty normal
stuff I was expecting bishop see to this
looks normal and then here was my was my
idea this kind of position and i thought
this should be about equal yeah i
managed I wasn't sure about those two
nite see I wanted to trade one of it one
of them and this is okay this is about
equal this position
but he went here here I actually should
have taken on b3 and taken I'm taking
this chance and now Bishop see two ish
he should play but here I actually did
take the exhibition 26 yeah and the
problem here simply if you look at this
white has moves moved almost all of his
pawns where's this King ever going to be
totally safe that's not so easy um the
maybe you can yeah you can replay what
the what the engine is suggesting night
f 1 2 g-3 with just a slight edge for
black now white also has a problem here
in terms terms of porn breaks the only
idea that he has left is f4 f5 and
that's not going to happen so easily
especially not after this yeah after
okay h5 yeah I was just thinking maybe
maybe this was was an idea but this is
no real compensation yeah it's a bit
weak ish this is this whole complex but
what's pieces are far away ya can't hear
now many many nice options really what
I'm maybe should do is to play this a 66
business now completely closed the
queenside so this is ok but c6 be for a
six yeah well honestly be five is not
working but i would just would have
liked to get to get through this game
without allowing these kind of things
but it is ultimately really not working
so minus minus quite quite a lot yeah ok
here the comp once played with Nigeria
keeping the corner
possible but this is just good right
still yeah it always keeps an advantage
I could have taken f4 maybe did not see
that one this is slightly messy now that
not serious yeah I could have taken it
for I did not really pay attention to
that at all I was thinking okay let's
let's push the pause here a pretty quick
decision which is not bad I mean I can I
can play like hey 5 some minus minus
1.645 going to comp yeah now white was
making this kind of desperate effort
yeah that's interesting here I just
recaptured I had some doubts about that
Oh rightly so hahaha I didn't see that
one coming checkmate nice so that that
was the idea I didn't even see that I
was just I was actually just saying this
and I thought oh well this isn't so
clear and so on okay so Queen takes and
now I'm ya know black is actually
winning it's just too much material also
yeah the problem is really was right out
of the opening he played some very
committal moves yeah like this G for
this is something that really has to be
considered very carefully because you
cannot come back from that you cannot
take this move back or correct this kind
of thing and yeah after that your
structure is just just so compromised
that it will be very difficult to get a
normal game it's just like that I think
white is in trouble here already and he
could have defended better but it's it's
simply not a very attractive position
you rather if it would be a cording to
the rules you would really play g4g for
back to
em but well fortunately that's not
possible okay i hope you enjoyed this
rapid game thanks for watching